hello everyone and welcome to the first
game we'll be showing from the oslo
esports cup it is the first event of the
uh major uh tournament series that is
the 1.6 million million dollar melt
weather champions uh chester uh young
shisht of duda vs magnus carlsen uh it
features a very very cool opening and
you guys will really enjoy this one
features an exchange sacrifice and um
well the quote above the board by david
bronstein really sums up this game very
well hope you hope you will agree with
this now let's check out the game there
is quite a lot to enjoy duda has the
wide pieces and opens with e4 now like i
said this is a rapid event players will
be playing four games or rapid and if
they that ends in a tie of course they
will go to a quicker time format so here
e4 and we all know what magnus plays uh
when he is faced with e4 he plays h5
that of course is a joke he plays c5 he
goes for the sicilian defense i'm just
checking if you guys always know what's
happening knight to f3 with e6 d4 uh
challenging the sicilian and now
captures in captures and we have a6 by
magnus going for the con variation uh
checking if duda has something prepared
for this he plays bishop to d3 this is
the modern way to challenge the khan
structure bishop to c5 attacking the
knight knight b3 attacking the bishop
and the bishop to a7 and now
it seems like uh the g7 pawn has been
left a little bit weak since the bishop
no longer guards it you might play
something like queen to g4 but black
would just ignore you knight to f6
attacks the queen and it's never a good
idea to capture this pawn here if you do
this then we can play bishop captures on
f2 and that's a problem if you capture
the this guy then we're going to play
rook to g8 attack the queen and after
this queen h6 move which is the only
square available for the queen that
we're gonna pick up the queen with this
beautiful fork so the variation is still
playable but after knight to f6 you
can't go upon grabbing you have to go
backwards to g3 and then the game
continues
so while queen to g4 is a viable option
uh duda says all right magnus obviously
prepared this very well let's just play
a nice calm queen to e2 knight to c6
magnus continues development and now
bishop to e3 challenging this very
strong bishop as the magnus did spend
quite a few moves getting it all the way
from f8 to a7 so d6 we have knight to c3
and now knight to f6 uh we have f4 now
grabbing more space here and now still
deciding whether to castle king side or
queen side and magnus strikes with b5
duda place a3 not allowing any a4 uh b4
ideas to challenge the knight on c3 and
here uh duda advances the pawn uh sorry
magnus advances the pawn to e5 and the
situation on the clock is duda has some
eight minutes on the clock magnus 12
minutes on the clock so um uh he's doing
a little bit better there
and there is a game where castles was
played here but here duda plays bishop
captures on a7 and it is now as of move
12 that we have a completely new game uh
magnus grabs the pawn back the piece
back with the with the rook rook
captures on a7 now he has very nice
control of the seventh rank and later on
you can even play rook to d7 maybe to
try and get to this pawn all the way to
d5 we know that that's uh what you
usually do with this pawn in a silent
defense and uh duda closes the center
with f5 so here magnus plays knight to
d4 and he asks duda what do you play
here right now this is the point of
preparation uh that duda is meeting uh
and it's a rapid game i uh uh well i
never seem to be able to stress this
enough uh the best way to counter this
is by playing queen to f2 now of course
it seems like the knight can't move
because the rook on a7 would hang but we
can just capture the knight because the
rook on a1 would be hanging as well and
now after c captures we're going to play
rook d7 trying to get this d5 move in
and that's how you want to play this
however duda played knight captures on
d4 first magnus captured back attacking
the knight here and now played queen to
f2 uh which is uh kind of giving magnus
a deadly there
but magnus after spending a minute on
deciding uh decides to capture it he's
uh very much
a lot on clock it's five minute versus
ten minutes for magnus so he captures
gives up the rook on a7 queen captures
on a7 and now c captures on b2 attacking
the rook on a1 so rook to b1 and now
this is all worth it because of this
queen to a5 check so we are not going to
allow white to the castle and maybe even
defend the
uh the past b2 pawn so here king to e2
and now
uh magnus just castles uh the absolute
best way probably if this was a
classical game would be just to defend
the pawn but magnus wants to open up the
center as soon as possible and now even
after something like queen b6 going
after the pawn we're still gonna castle
so it's maybe better to give up this
pawn then pile up on the e4 pawn we're
just attacking it with everything rupees
coming to e8 it would be very very
difficult for duda to survive this uh
but magnus uh wants to play very
actively he just castles we have queen
to d4 dude centralizes the queen back
now puts more pressure on the b2 pawn so
now you can't really defend the pawn uh
rook to e8 going after the e pawn and
now rook h to e1 giving up the f5 pawn
as the pawn is pinned at
survive the attack so bishop captures an
f5 by magnus king to f1 and now bishop
back to g6 so you have this position
magnus still down the exchange but he
has a very very active position rook
captures on b2 finally duda gets rid of
this past pawn queen captures an a3
magnus creating another pass pawn now
and here comes rook to b4 here duda kind
of misses the opportunity to force a
queen trade with uh queen to before
there's no way
uh to actually avoid this trade and it
would be uh very good for him but then
again uh it will not be it will not be
incredibly easy playing this end game
especially since it's rapid and uh as
duda is very low on the clock so here we
have rook to b4 now blocking the queen's
defense of the d6 pawn dude and wants to
capture the pawn uh queen to a5 and now
queen captures on d6 with h6 magnus
creates some breeding room for his king
and now comes rook to d4 uh we have
knights to g4 uh and now comes h3
kicking the knight away knight to e5 and
now queen to c5 so uh what can magnus
play here uh well uh there are quite a
lot of ideas here he plays queen to d2
uh gets the queen out of the way from
the a file now you can start pushing
your pawn if uh
an opportunity presents itself uh and uh
it's uh duda to play so can do that take
advantage of this uh rook x-raying the
queen on d2 not really the problem is if
you play anything like bishop captures
on b5 you open up a discovery here queen
f4 check and you just
wasted a perfectly good bishop so after
queen to d2 do the plays rook to d5
threatens the wind material here and
magnus defends it with f6 now this is
one of those positions where f6 is is a
fine move to play especially since duda
is incredibly low on the clock he has
some 30 seconds whereas magnus has two
and a half minutes so here we have queen
to e3 now offering a queen trade and of
course magnus declines he wants as much
stuff on the board as possible for duda
to waste as much time as possible queen
d4 we have bishop to f7 now challenging
the rook here rook d6 now knight to c4
and here duda should again just consider
capturing but i think due to
a low time on the clock he just trusts
magnus that this is good for him because
if captures captures dude i can just
play king f2 and he retains a better
position however here rook the a1
attacking carlson's queen queen to d2
now uh seemingly uh now dude i can trade
here and open up a discovery to the
black queen but now after bishop
captures on c4 which is the absolute
best move for duda queen f4 check king
to g1 and the bishop captures on c4 we
have rook to d8 duda finally gets rid of
carlson's rook honey eight rook captures
on the e8 queen capture 78 and now came
to h7 and now
rook back to e1 to guard the e5 pawn but
now magnus plays queen to e5 he will put
a bishop on e6 and as the queen is on e5
it's not going to be
all that easy for duda to come up with a
viable plan uh so here queen to d7 that
now comes bishop to e6 attacks the queen
queen to d3 now a5 now the pawns start
marching forward and it's not going to
be easy to stop them we have c3 they're
preventing b4 but now magnus pushes a4
and here your only way of continuing
this is queen to d4 there is no other
move for duda besides that but he played
rook to b1 and this of course allows
magnus to just break through
with those pawns we have a3 now a2 is
coming rook to a1 and now an even
greater threat b4 now of course you
cannot capture because queen captures
rook on a1 so king to f2 was played and
here magnus just played b3 and he was in
this position animal 43 that young [ __ ]
of duda resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done here
i would ask you to pause the video and
uh figure out what happens if rook
captures an a3 but i know everyone sees
that queen the c5 check picks up the
rook and that's why of course duda had
to resign the game gear as the pawns are
now unstoppable uh so yeah that's the
game hope you guys enjoyed it like i
said i hope braunstein's quote sums it
up very well so and it wasn't really uh
an examination of knowledge but actually
a battle battle of nerves uh magnus had
long-term pressure he sacrificed um the
exchange and the duda fought uh fought
well uh took him too much time and in
the end he just didn't have enough time
to to continue fighting back uh so
that's the game the first game of the uh
of the oslo uh esports cup hope you guys
enjoyed it next one coming is the one
that already you guys have suggested and
i see that suggestions are uh coming as
i'm recording uh for the uh fun forest
pragananda game
uh so that one is coming up next uh i
would like to thank pratam shekhar
mahajan usfd efra usfdfri nicolas padal
and andrew dabrovsky for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon continuing with the
game that i just mentioned uh so thank
you all i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day